after a brutal week of bombings the
Ukrainian response
a fuel Depot inside Russian occupied
Crimea Up in Smoke
the objective is to reclaim the whole of
the Crimea because it's always Sovereign
part of our nation the Drone attack led
the Moscow installed governor of the
region to close a bridge linking the
peninsula to Russia despite the Fuel
Depot being more than 160 kilometers
away
the only link from Russia to Crimea
suffered serious damage last week and
attacked the ukrainians have not taken
responsibility for but Vladimir
zielinski believes it is a legitimate
military Target decrement rage this is
not just a logistical Road
this is the roots used to
speed the war with ammunition and this
has been done on a daily basis
and it militarizes the Crimean peninsula
the attack led to Fierce Russian bombing
across Ukraine with a key focus on
Odessa the port city that was the hub
for Ukrainian grain shipments which also
stopped last week after Russia pulled
out of a deal guaranteeing the safety of
cargo ships the new wave of attacks on
Ukrainian ports risks having
far-reaching impacts on Global Food
Security in particular in developing
countries grain prices have spiked nine
percent since the rush Ukraine deal
ended which is set to hurt countries
across Africa and the Middle East hard
many of whom have stayed neutral or even
supported Vladimir Putin's war in
Ukraine Mackenzie gray Global News